und nun zum Geschehen im Deutschen
Bundestag dort geht es heute früh um die
Lage der Krankenkassen er hat schärfer
mein Kollege hat sich dazu Gäste
eingeladen er hat mit Blick auf die
Krankenkassen da ist ja von einem von
Milliarden Löcher und die Rede was heißt
denn das genau wie groß sind denn die
Löcher das
das weiß man im Moment noch gar nicht
richtig an zu einer fitkau die Rede ist
häufig von 17 Milliarden Euro die im
nächsten Jahr fehlen könnten aber es
gibt doch ganz andere Zahlen die gehen
in den Bereiche von 22 Milliarden oder
sogar noch mehr so richtig fest scheint
das auch noch nicht zu stehen aber es
ist Handlungsbedarf da ist gar keine
Frage und deswegen wird heute in erster
Lesung über ein Gesetzentwurf zur
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Gesundheitsversorgung im Parlament
diskutiert wir nehmen ein paar Punkte
schon mal vorab und ich freue mich dass
heute morgen bei uns sind Heike Behrens
die gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD Bundestagsfraktion und Sepp Müller
ist bei uns aus der Unionsfraktion da
ist der stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender und hat unter
anderem das Themengebiet Gesundheit
mitzuverantworten Frau Behrens was ist
der Grund für das aktuell erwartete
Defizit eigentlich ja ich glaube es sind
viele Gründe das eine ist natürlich dass
wir eine Pandemie nach wie vor zu
durchstehen haben die uns auch im
Gesundheitssystem enorm herausgefordert
hat und die auch mit dazu geführt hat
dass so manche Reformen die eigentlich
naheliegen nicht angepackt worden also
beispielsweise im Bereich der
Krankenhäuser oder auch was eben der das
Arzneimittel neuordnungsgesetz anlangt
wo wir eigentlich wissen was zu tun ist
aber das ist ein bisschen auf die lange
Bank geschoben worden am Ende der
letzten Legislaturperiode und jetzt muss
es angepackt werden aktuelle Probleme
nennt Frau Behrens Herr Müller auf der
anderen Seite auch strukturelle wie
beispielsweise die Lage der
Krankenhäuser sind Sie einverstanden mit
der Analyse im Großen und Ganzen gut wir
haben das eine Thema ist das sind die
Krankenhäuser wir haben das andere Thema
das ist das Thema ambulantisierung wir
wissen seit April von einem Gutachten
dass 2476 Leistungen ambulant
durchgeführt werden können ich bin das
beste Beispiel zwei Kreuzbandrisse das
kann man entweder ambulant durchführen
oder stationär im ambulanten Bereich
kostet es die Hälfte und da müssen wir
fitter werden und uns die
internationalen Partner anschauen das
können die besser und in die Richtung
muss es gehen auf der anderen Seite
soweit ich mich kann und soweit ich mich
so seitdem ich mich für Politik
interessiere ist immer wieder und immer
wieder die Finanzierung der
Krankenkassen ein großes Thema warum
gelingt es nicht das ganze mal
mittelfristig zu stabilisieren naja wir
befinden uns wirklich in der größten
Gesundheitskrise die wir in der
Nachkriegszeit hatten das muss man
einfach schon konzipieren aber wir haben
auf der anderen Seite wirklich auch ganz
grundlegende Probleme natürlich wenn die
Lasten der Gesundheitsversorgung
ausschließlich auf dem Rücken der
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
liegen dann heißt das natürlich auch
dass Schwankungen beispielsweise im
Wirtschaftsbereich wenn Kurzarbeit
gemacht wird wie wir das in den letzten
zwei Jahren ja mehrfach hatten dann
führt das zu Mindereinnahmen in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung während
die Ausgaben weiter
steigendemographiebedingt oder auch
aufgrund des medizinischen Fortschritts
und dann muss halt immer wieder neu eine
Balance hergestellt werden und dieses
Mal geht es darum wirklich
ein großes Defizit abzufedern die
Balance soll hergestellt werden
zumindest sind dass die Pläne des
Gesundheitsministers die sie ja
wahrscheinlich mittragen ich durch eine
ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen ich sage nur
ein paar Stichworte weil wir das im
Detail ja gar nicht richtig erörtern
konnten können es geht um die Anhebung
des Zusatzbeitrags es geht um eine extra
Abgabe der Pharmaindustrie es geht um
einen höheren Steuerzuschuss an den
Gesundheitsfonds der wiederum Geld
auszahlt an die Krankenkassen es geht um
ein Darlehen für den Bund an die
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung zum
Solidarbeiträge der Krankenkassen aus
deren Reserven und eine Erhöhung des
apothekenumschlags und Abschlags und
dann habe ich die Abschaffung der
neupatientenpauschale jetzt fast
vergessen aber dann doch nicht welchen
Punkt Herr Müller würden Sie sagen ja
das ist gut gut dass wir das so dass sie
im Koalition und das Gesundheitsminister
das so angeht ich habe am Anfang der
Legislaturperiode den Koalitionsvertrag
gelobt dass er unter anderem vorsieht
die Arbeitslosengeld 2 Bezieher und
Empfänger eins zu eins auszugleichen das
wären 10 Milliarden Euro da steht im
Koalitionsvertrag drin ich bin etwas
Gesetz dass diese Flickschusterei die
jetzt vorgelegt wird nicht dazu dienen
strukturell etwas zu tun insbesondere
dass der Koalitionsvertrag nicht
umgesetzt wird und darum kann ich zu dem
Punkt nur sagen das ist nichts Halbes
und nichts Ganzes das wird uns nicht
helfen wir brauchen strukturellen
Zuschuss das ist das Thema
Arbeitslosengeld 2-empfänger deshalb
verstanden welche von den Punkten würden
sie trotzdem sagen okay gut dass man es
angeht weil es wird ja auch mehrere
Schultern verteilt also die Versicherten
sind dran die Apotheken sind werden zur
Kasse gebeten
Pharmaindustrie also wir hören von allen
Beteiligten in der Branche das ist nicht
ausreichend ist und diese Punkte sind
nicht ausreichend ich kann da keinen
Punkt rausgreifen den ich lobend erwähne
schade jetzt haben wir es ich will da
vielleicht mal einen Haken weil den
Ausgleich für die zu geringen Beiträge
für die alg2-bezieher wollte die
SPD-Fraktion auch in der letzten
Legislaturperiode sehr gern mit der
cdu/csu auf dem Weg bringen und sie
wissen dass es ihre Fraktion war die das
abgelehnt hat noch nicht gemacht hat von
daher ist das ein bisschen wohlfrei wenn
man jetzt in der Opposition mit einer
sagt das was ihr damals wolltet das
würden wir jetzt mitmachen also ich habe
gerade überlegt ob ich ihn nicht ein
Beitrittsformular für die SPD
überreichen soll während ich habe schon
drauf gewartet dass Sie das sagen aber
ich glaube der Finanzminister den
Haushaltsplan aufgelegt hat dass es der
jetzige Bundeskanzler und ich habe da
ganz andere Informationen das nehme ich
in der haushaltsausstellung genau der
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz auf die
Einhaltung des Koalitionsvertrages in
dem Punkt verzichtet hat sie hören das
wieder und wieder von uns wir müssen die
Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger das sind
10 Milliarden Euro mit beteiligen das
ist eine volkswirtschaftliche Komponente
und ich kann es keiner Verkäuferin in
einem Supermarkt mit 1500 Euro brutto
erklären warum sie denjenigen
subventioniert der zu Hause sitzt das
funktioniert nicht das ist eine Aufgabe
des Staates und da stehen wir an der
Seite der geringenverdiener die jetzt
quersubventionieren Arbeitslosengeld
zwei Empfänger das ist wunderbar wie sie
das Argumentieren und wissen dass das
die Position der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
ist
Herr Müller erstmal wünsche ich mir dass
sie sich durchsetzen ihre eigenen
Fraktion nämlich saß ja am Montagabend
mit Herrn sorge also ihrem
gesundheitspolitischen Sprecher auf dem
Podium bei der AOK und da wurde er das
Thema angesprochen und hat er gesagt das
ist eine Einzelmeinung in unserer
Fraktion also es ist mitnichten die
Position der cdu/csu und das finde ich
jetzt nicht ganz in Ordnung hier den
Eindruck zu erwecken als wären sie da
jetzt diejenigen die endlich zu den
Gerechten Beiträgen der alg2-bezieher
eintreten würden wir stehen jedenfalls
dafür und wir werden auch im weiteren
Verfahren und dafür einsetzen ich gehe
mal noch ein bisschen Input hier in
dieses muntere Gespräch in einem
namensbeitrag für die Frankfurter
Allgemeine Zeitung haben sie Anfang
September vorgeschlagen Herr Müller die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anzuheben aber
auch die
Versicherungspflichtgrenze wie viel
Unterstützung weil ich nehme den Punkt
mal von Frau Behrens eben auf wie viel
Unterstützung haben Sie für diese forder
innerhalb ihrer Fraktion und in ihrer
Partei ich habe Jubelstürme bekommen aus
allen Bereichen der Partei sie wissen
wir sind eine Volkspartei wir wissen
auch dass starke Schultern mehr leisten
müssen als schwacher tragen können und
vor dem Hintergrund gehen wir am
Dienstag gemeinsam in eine Klausur und
werden die Punkte die ich vorgeschlagen
habe unter anderem das von Ihnen
genannte aber vier weitere Punkte auch
miteinander besprechen und dann sehen
wir mal wie wir es am Ende ausgeht muss
ihren Jubelsturm glaube ich ein bisschen
korrigieren ich habe nämlich heute
morgen den bayerischen
Gesundheitsminister Holidaycheck in
Deutschlandfunk gehört der
im Grunde gar nicht eingegangen ist auf
diese beiden Punkten da hat sie quasi
zur Kenntnis genommen aber dass er sie
unterstützt hätte kann man nur weiß Gott
nicht sagen eigentlich ist das aber doch
eine gute Idee dieser Vorschlag
abgesehen davon dass es wie irgendwie
nicht sicher bin ob die Mehrheit in der
Unionsfraktion der tatsächlich steht
warum ist die SPD da nicht drauf
gekommen darauf sind wir allerdings
gekommen wir haben auch in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen genau für das
Thema uns eingesetzt weil es völlig
richtig ist wie ist Herr Müller gerade
dar erzählt hat starke Schultern müssen
mehr tragen als die schwächeren und
deshalb ist es überfällig dass man die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anhebt in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen war das noch
nicht möglich das mit der FDP zu einem
aber ich denke schon wenn es jetzt darum
geht wirklich dieses historisch hohe
strukturelle Defizit der Kassen
auszugleichen dann müssen wir dieses
Thema tatsächlich noch mal auf die
Tagesordnung bringen aber ich will schon
noch mal eins sagen Herr Möller weil das
hat ja immer auch was mit persönlicher
Glaubwürdigkeit zu tun und das sieht zum
Beispiel genau zum Jahresbeginn 2022 was
man ja ihren eigen ihrer eigenen
Homepage entnehmen kann in die private
Krankenversicherung gewechselt sind als
einer der eben ein hohes Einkommen hat
dann nehmen sie sich ja quasi aus der
Solidargemeinschaft heraus der
gesetzlich Versicherten und ich finde
das passt nicht so ganz damit zusammen
wenn Sie jetzt die Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze fordern dürfen
Sie gerne
ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun das
Gute ist dass wir uns unterscheiden beim
Thema Bürgerversicherung ich glaube ihr
System ist ja dass wenn die Bürger dass
sie eine Bürgerversicherung wollen dass
alle einzahlen das wollen wir nicht wir
wollen bewusst dass beide Systeme
nebeneinander funktionieren wir wollen
nicht das amerikanische System nur
privat wir wollen nicht nur das
britische System wo ab einem gewissen
Alter nur 30.000 Euro für die
medizinische Versorgung zur Verfügung
steht das wollen wir nicht darum möchten
wir das beide Systeme im System bleiben
und da brauche ich mich gar nicht
verstecken wie andere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auch wir haben eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe und da
gilt es jetzt gemeinsam zusammenzustehen
und da trägt die PKV die private
Krankenversicherung ihren Beitrag
unterträgt die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung auch ihren weiter
aber wenn sie wie Frau Behrendt sagt ein
richtigerweise sagen
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anheben und
Versicherungspflichtgrenze annehmen sind
sie ja trotzdem auf dem Weg dahin und
das was sie was vor Behrens eben auch
gesagt hat das sind ja noch mal also
starke Schultern das eine ist das Thema
bürgerver und das andere Thema ist dass
wir beide Systeme miteinander erhalten
wollen wir haben alles auf den Tisch
gelegt ich glaube auch Vorschläge die
man von der Fraktion nicht erwartet
hätte dann merkt man ja auch an den
Reaktionen die uns dann eher Zustimmung
geben und wir müssen in ein
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kompromiss
jetzt diese Mammutaufgabe GKV
Finanzierung und Krankenkassen
Finanzierung an dem Weg im wir reichen
die Hand auch der Ampelkoalition und
möchten diesen Weg gemeinsam beschreiten
und freuen uns auf die Einladung um hier
eine Lösung herbeizuführen wir werden
das beobachten weil du im neuen Jahr
auch die Debatte dazu stattfindet ich
habe nur einen Punkt noch wo ich ihre
Meinung gerne noch zu wüsste es gibt
auch Vorschläge aus den Krankenkassen
und da ist mir aufgefallen zum einen
wird vorgeschlagen eine Zuckersteuer
einzuführen weil ja gerade durch Zucker
und falsche Ernährung auch das Kranken
Gesundheitssystem belastet wird und auf
der anderen Seite gab es einen Vorschlag
die Krankenkassen zu beteiligen an
Einnahmen aus Tabak und Alkoholsteuer
wie stehen Sie dazu
definitiv müssen wir in unserem
Gesundheitssystem den
Aspekt der Gesundheitsvorsorge und
Prävention Stärken weil wir ja es muss
stärker unser Anliegen sein das krank
werden zu vermeiden und von daher sind
diese Vorschläge natürlich gehen in eine
sinnvolle Richtung wie aber die
Geldströme am Ende laufen das muss
politisch entschieden werden darüber
müssen wir diskutieren aber alles was
der Gesundheitsvorsorge und Prävention
dient ist auf jeden Fall wichtig und da
müssen wir noch einen Schritt
weiterkommen es ist ihre Perspektive
Herr Müller dabei ja gut zusätzliche
Steuern zu erheben um in das bereits
großes System einzuzahlen da mache ich
mal ein großes Fragezeichen dahinter wir
haben strukturelle Probleme sie haben
einiges angesprochen ob da zusätzliche
Geldeinnahmen helfen diese strukturellen
Probleme die da sind zu lösen groß
Fragezeichen
die strukturellen Probleme lösen und
trotzdem dafür sorgen dass die Kassen
genug Geld zur Verfügung haben für das
was sie eigentlich leisten sollen Frau
während vielen Dank dass Sie heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch Ihnen
Herr Müller vielen Dank